The cause of all the catastrophes we are seeing today is overpopulation.
We are proud to unveil the only practical remedy to humanity's greatest problem.
Are you ready, Doctor?
Yes, I'm ready.
Wow, that is wild, isn't it?
It's just wild.
In Leisure Land, your 52,000 dollars translates to 12.5 million dollars to live on for life.
Wow.
Do you understand that you will undergo the permanent...
...and irreversible medical procedure commonly known as downsizing...
...and that your bodies will be approximately 0.0364% of their current mass and volume?
Nervous?
A little.
I'll see you on the other side.
Sometimes you think we're in the normal world and then something happens...
Oh my God.
...and you realize we're not.